Imagine spending years in a career only to realise the part that truly lights you up isn't what you're trained to do. That's what happened for today's guest, Manisha, who worked in radiotherapy helping cancer patients through life-saving treatment. But it was when she supported patients' mental health, calming panic attacks, easing fear and helping them feel safe that she realized where her real purpose was. So with a family, a mortgage and a steady career, she decided to start again. In this episode, we talk about what it really takes to retrain later in life, the fear, the finances, the family juggle and the freedom that comes from finally doing something that aligns with your values. If you've ever wondered whether it's too late to change direction, this episode might just be the permission slip you need. I hope you find it really useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast.
想象一下，在一个职业中投入了多年，最后却发现真正让你兴奋的部分并不是你受过培训要做的事情。今天的嘉宾曼妮莎（Manisha）就是这样，她曾在放射治疗领域工作，帮助癌症患者度过挽救生命的治疗。但正是当她支持患者的心理健康、平息恐慌发作、缓解恐惧并让他们感到安全时，她才意识到自己真正的目标所在。因此，在有家庭、有房贷和稳定职业的情况下，她决定重新开始。在本集节目中，我们讨论了在晚年重新培训真正需要的东西、恐惧、财务、家庭兼顾以及最终做一些符合你价值观的事情所带来的自由。如果你曾怀疑改变方向是否为时已晚，这一集可能就是你需要的准许证。希望你觉得它真的很有用，如果你喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到有抱负的心理学家播客。
I'm Dr. Marianne. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. And today I am joined by our guest, Manisha, who is a psychological well-being practitioner. Hi, Minisha. Hello, Marianne. Thank you so much for being here. And, you know, for helping us to expand the narrative that it's always okay to listen to your inner kind of thoughts, feelings, maybe sometimes even bodily sensations,
我是玛丽安（Marianne）博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天，我们的嘉宾曼妮莎加入了我们，她是一名心理健康从业者。嗨，曼妮莎。你好，玛丽安。非常感谢你能来到这里。而且，你知道，感谢你帮助我们扩展这种叙述：倾听你内心深处的想法、感觉，甚至有时是身体感觉，永远都是可以的，
that maybe the career you're in is not for you. And retraining, regardless of your age, is an option worth exploring. Could you tell us a little bit about your history and where you're at, Manisha? Yeah. So I suppose I've always had a passion for psychology, for mental health, for helping others and understanding others for a long time. And initially, I suppose, I wanted to do psychology, but didn't feel like it was quite right when I originally went to university to do it. So I decided to train in radiotherapy, which is treating cancer patients and helping them to get through radiotherapy treatment.
也许你从事的职业并不适合你。无论你的年龄如何，重新培训都是一个值得探索的选择。曼妮莎，你能跟我们讲讲你的经历和目前的状况吗？好的。所以我想我一直对心理学、心理健康、帮助他人以及理解他人有着长期的热情。最初，我想我想要从事心理学，但当我最初上大学时，觉得它并不完全适合我。所以我决定接受放射治疗方面的培训，也就是治疗癌症患者并帮助他们度过放射治疗。
So it's been a really rewarding role in career because I've been able to help others. kind of something I strongly value. So I suppose in my career, natural career progression, I've kind of moved up in my job and then, and I guess I've always thought the purpose of that was to kind of get to the next step. And I think once I kind of got to that kind of final position of where I wanted to be, I started to think, actually I'm not really sure, is this for me, is this what I want going forward? And I started training in various things of where, you know, I place more value. So that was like in supporting cancer patients with their mental help to help them get through treatment, people who struggle with anxiety, depression, claustrophobia.
所以这是一个非常有价值的角色和职业，因为我能够帮助别人。这可以说是我强烈的价值观。所以我想在我的职业生涯中，自然的职业发展让我提升了职位，然后，我想我一直认为这样做的目的是为了迈向下一步。我想一旦我达到了我想要达到的那个最终职位，我开始思考，实际上我真的不确定，这适合我吗，这就是我以后想要的吗？我开始接受各种培训，在那里（你知道的）我赋予了更多的价值。也就是支持癌症患者的心理健康，帮助他们度过治疗，帮助那些与焦虑、抑郁、幽闭恐惧症作斗争的人。
So helping them to manage and I really like, really felt for those patients and thought, you know what, I want to do more here. And my passion is actually more about helping people with their mental health than not necessarily treating them because obviously I wanted to do that. That was part of my job. But I felt like my focus has changed. shifted or maybe was always there but kind of didn't listen to those niggles along the way that kind of was pushing me in that direction. Okay, so if people are like, oh, I thought radiographer was someone that x-rays broken bones, that's not quite what you've been trained in. That's not quite what you were doing, is it? No, that's, so diagnostic radiotherapy is a little
所以帮助他们应对，我真的非常同情这些患者，并心想：你知道吗，我想在这里做更多的事情。我的热情实际上更多在于帮助人们解决心理健康问题，而不仅仅是治疗他们，因为显然我想那样做。那是我的工作的一部分。但我觉得我的重心已经改变了，或者也许一直都在那里，只是没有听从这一路上把我往那个方向推的那些小烦恼。好的，如果人们在想，哦，我以为放射技师是给骨折拍X光的人，那并不是你受过培训的内容。那不是你一直在做的事，对吧？不，那，所以诊断性放射治疗有点
bit different. So those are the people who x-ray patients for different things. Radiotherapy, so a therapeutic radiographer is someone who will treat cancer patients going through the treatment of radiotherapy. So for example, different patient cancer patients like to have different treatments such as chemotherapy. So radiotherapy is one of the treatments that are using ionising radiation to treat a patient's cancer, basically. Thank you. That's really helpful. It's reminded me of when my dad was having cancer treatment.
不同。这些人是为不同事情给患者拍X光的人。放射治疗，也就是治疗性放射技师，是治疗接受放射治疗的癌症患者的人。例如，不同的癌症患者喜欢接受不同的治疗，比如化疗。所以放射治疗是利用电离辐射来治疗患者癌症的治疗方法之一，基本上就是这样。谢谢。这真的很有帮助。它让我想起了我父亲接受癌症治疗的时候。
He had to have it on his, he had it's offered you or cancer. I think he had some sort of mask made for his face. So that's sometimes why some patients can feel a bit claustrophobic because they have to be laid in a mask on the bed that's kind of pinned down to the bed and they've got to be still to have their radiotherapy treatment. Okay, so just remind us or just illuminate us then. What's the function of that mask?
他必须在，他是在他身上进行的，或者是喉癌。我想他的脸做过某种面具。所以这就是为什么有些患者会感到有点幽闭恐惧症的原因，因为他们必须躺在床上戴着面具，面具被固定在床上，他们必须保持不动才能接受放射治疗。好的，那么请提醒我们，或者为我们阐明一下。那个面具的作用是什么？
Is that just to immobilise the patient or is there some magic that happens? Yeah. So that's to all patients will have certain immobilisation to keep them still in the bed. Obviously, if we're using radiation, we don't want to miss what we're treating or we don't want to, you know, it's very accurate, very precise and it's becoming more targeted. So we have immobilization aids to help keep the patient in the correct. correct position for their treatment. They do also have images taken as well to again check that we're in the right position. We're happy that their position is consistent and throughout their treatment because some patients can come for one treatment and some patients can come for a course
那只是为了固定患者，还是有什么神奇的事情发生？是的。这就是让所有患者都进行一定的固定，以保持他们在床上的静止。显然，如果我们使用辐射，我们不想错过我们正在治疗的部位，或者我们不想，你知道的，这是非常准确、非常精确的，并且正变得越来越有针对性。所以我们有固定辅助工具来帮助患者保持正确的位置以进行治疗。他们还会拍摄图像，再次检查我们是否处于正确的位置。我们很高兴他们的位置在整个治疗过程中是一致的，因为有些患者会来接受一次治疗，有些患者会来接受一个疗程
of radiotherapy. I see. So the masks would be kind of fixed to the bed where they're having the treatment so that they can't move. So yeah, I can absolutely understand why that might feel claustrophobic yes okay so that's you know even in this listening to this podcast people are able to help think about their own upskilling their own knowledge but of course we're also thinking about yeah that you recognize that maybe some of the more therapeutic aspects were just hitting different for you yeah and I think when I went into radiotherapy initially so though there are those two routes I wanted to do more of the therapeutic side for that reason but I suppose because cancer is becoming you know it's there's more and more people
的放射治疗。我明白了。所以面具会被固定在他们接受治疗的床上，这样他们就不能移动。所以，是的，我完全理解为什么这会让人感到幽闭恐惧症，是的，好的，所以，你知道，即使在听这个播客时，人们也能够帮助思考他们自己的技能提升、他们自己的知识，但当然我们也在思考，是的，你认识到也许一些更多治疗方面的对你来说有不同的感觉。是的，我认为当我最初进入放射治疗时，尽管有这两条路线，但由于这个原因，我更想做治疗方面的工作，但我想因为癌症正在变得（你知道的）有越来越多的人
experiencing cancer so focus is on getting patients through treatment and obviously there's waiting time so the priority is to get cancer patients through their treatment unless I'd say focus on psychological side the impact of that on cancer patients especially going through treatment So as part of what we call the patient support team who then specialise in helping cancer patients get through treatment who are struggling. It's just giving them that extra sort of support through their treatment. It might be talking to them beforehand, but really it's about providing them support to get on the bed to get through their treatment. So people who might have panic attacks or who might feel very anxious to help calm them down. So it's like talking to them over the intercom, doing some brew.
经历癌症，所以重点是让患者度过治疗，显然有等待时间，所以首要任务是让癌症患者度过他们的治疗，除非我说专注于心理方面、这对癌症患者的影响，尤其是正在经历治疗的患者。所以作为我们所说的患者支持团队的一部分，他们专门帮助那些苦苦挣扎的癌症患者度过治疗。这只是在他们的治疗过程中给他们那种额外的支持。可能是在事先与他们交谈，但实际上是为他们提供支持，让他们上床接受治疗。比如那些可能会恐慌发作或感到非常焦虑的人，帮助他们平静下来。所以就像通过对讲机跟他们说话，做一些深呼吸，
reading and some patients we did some graded exposure when they're experiencing the mask and struggling with that. Thank you and how lovely that you have been able to see the distress in the client be moved by that distress and want to help them to get through essential treatment because it really matters, doesn't it? You know, the engagement of this treatment being successful means that they will get hopefully more days, more weeks, more months, maybe even more years, more decades. sometimes with to live life you know to be part of of their own life yeah I think it's a
还有一些患者，当他们经历面具并为此苦苦挣扎时，我们做了一些分级暴露。谢谢你，你能看到客户的痛苦，被这种痛苦打动，并希望帮助他们度过必不可少的治疗，这是多么美好啊，因为这真的很重要，对吧？你知道，这种治疗成功的参与意味着他们希望能够获得更多天数、更多周、更多月，甚至更多年、更多十年。
real struggle if someone's really struggling with their mental health and then they can't go through treatment because they're struggling so much to get through with their mental health and I think that's really difficult you know for anyone going through any sort of health condition or treatment but then to have that kind of or maybe feel like they don't have that option because of their mental health and struggling with that. It just didn't quite sit right with me and I think, you know, I wanted to help people to be like, actually, you know, you can do this and I feel like I'm quite a compassionate person. So I think that sometimes we all just need a little bit of help and support and we can get through, you know, with that kind of right help,
如果一个人在心理健康方面苦苦挣扎，然后因为心理健康挣扎得太厉害而无法进行治疗，我认为这真的是一个真正的挣扎，我认为这对于任何经历任何健康状况或治疗的人来说都非常困难，然后有这种感觉，或者觉得自己因为心理健康而没有这种选择，并为此苦苦挣扎。这让我觉得有点不对劲，而且我认为，你知道，我想帮助人们说，实际上，你知道，你可以做到这一点，我觉得我是一个很有同情心的人。所以我想有时我们都只需要一点点帮助和支持，我们就可以挺过去，有了那种正确的帮助，
right support. So I think how we are as professionals can make a big difference and a big impact on other people, you know, and it's sometimes just the little things that we can do. So yeah, I think that's, you know, really important. Absolutely. Absolutely it is. And, you know, they deserve to have a good experience, but also you deserve as a clinician to feel like you're living your best life as well. So how old were you when you started to actively pursue kind of retraining options? I suppose when I had my child, so around 2017, I actually trained to be a coach in the NHS. So I trained as a coach and I was super passionate about that because again, it allows me to help people to reach their goals.
正确的支持。所以我觉得我们作为专业人士的表现可以对其他人产生巨大的差异和巨大的影响，你知道，有时这只是我们能做的小事。所以是的，我认为这（你知道的）非常重要。绝对的。绝对是的。而且，你知道，他们理应拥有良好的体验，但作为临床医生，你也理应觉得自己正在过着最好的生活。那么当你开始积极追求某种重新培训选择时，你多大？我想当我有了孩子时，大约在2017年，我实际上在NHS接受了教练培训。所以我接受了教练培训，我对此超级热情，因为同样地，这让我能够帮助人们实现他们的目标。
And again, that was something that I was really passionate about. and then I kind of brought that into the service to also help. So that I'd be helping staff in the wider trust, but also I wanted to help people in our department who wanted to look at their career progression. And again, with interviews, sometimes people would feel quite anxious going through an interview to supporting them in different ways,
同样，这也是我真正充满热情的事情。然后我把这一点带到了服务中去帮助。所以我将帮助更广泛的信托基金中的员工，但我也想帮助我们部门中那些希望关注自己职业发展的人。同样，在面试中，有时人们在经历面试时会感到相当焦虑，以不同的方式支持他们，
where that kind of, I suppose, mental health kind of creeped in as well. So that was another thing that I'd started doing there. So I think that really, I suppose having that time out when I had my, when I was off on Matt leave, kind of made me think, oh, do you want something a bit more and I want to be doing more of where I'm focused on helping people, but helping people get through to the other side. So that, I think, probably started things off really. and I suppose that's kind of what has led me to there, but I think I've always had that. What I've been told about career, you know, you get your next level and then you go, you know,
那种（我想）心理健康也悄悄潜入的地方。所以这是我在那里开始做的另一件事。所以我想真的，我猜在产假期间有那种时间离开，让我觉得，哦，你想要更多一点的东西吗，我想做更多专注于帮助人们的事情，但帮助人们度过难关。所以我想，这大概真的是事情的开始。我想这就是引导我到那里的原因，但我认为我一直都有这种想法。关于职业，我被告知的是，你知道，你得到了下一个级别，然后你去，你知道，
and you just keep on going. And I think sometimes we don't stop and think, is this really what I want and is this what I want to do? Because it doesn't have to be, well, you just keep on going up the career ladder. It does that fit in line with your values, your purpose? And I think those are the things to sit in, consider. Yeah, and it's also, as you go up that career ladder, you know, your standard of
然后你继续前进。我想有时我们不会停下来想想，这真的是我想要的吗，这是我想做的吗？因为不一定非得是你一直在职业阶梯上往上爬。这符合你的价值观、你的目标吗？我认为这些是需要坐下来考虑的事情。是的，随着你沿着职业阶梯往上爬，你知道，你的生活水平
living probably and your salary and your banding gets higher. And then you've obviously got, you know, dependent as well. You've got your son who's probably around eight years old, you know, and they are not cheap. Keeping them in Robux alone is difficult. You know, and then when you're thinking about retraining into a psychology career, you're like this is probably going to involve quite quite the pay cut so it's not you know there's often lots of factors involved yeah definitely so i think with psychology it's always kind of be there do i go and i kept seeing things or you know thinking but again i was thinking of that pay cut and how i don't you know manage with that but i suppose um one big thing that did have an impact on my career
可能还有你的薪水和级别都会变高。然后你显然也有（你知道的）抚养对象。你有一个大约八岁的儿子，你知道，他们可不便宜。光是让他们穿Robux（游戏皮肤）就很困难。然后，当你考虑转行进入心理学职业时，你会觉得这可能需要相当大的降薪，所以这不是，你知道的，通常涉及很多因素。是的，绝对的。所以我觉得对于心理学，它一直都在那里，我去吗，我一直看到事情，或者（你知道的）想着，但我又在考虑那个降薪以及我将如何（你知道的）应付那个，但我想，一个对我的职业生涯产生了影响的重大事情
was my health, like I struggled with my health a lot, and I knew that I needed things to be a bit differently. And I also believe sometimes that your health search sometimes might show up when you're kind of not fully aligned with where you're at as well. So I learned through my health journey that actually that my health was probably having an impact because things weren't really truly in line. And again, I knew that I needed to do something, but I think it took my health to really be like, no, something's, I've got to make a change and do something and it's taken that for me to really realise. I think I would have still made a change, but I think I was, you know, I was dizzering for a while and that was like the kind of final deciding thing that actually
是我的健康，我与我的健康做了很多斗争，我知道我需要事情变得有点不同。我也相信有时你的健康有时可能会在你不完全与你所处的位置保持一致时表现出来。所以我通过我的健康之旅了解到，实际上我的健康可能正在产生影响，因为事情并不是真正地保持一致。同样，我知道我需要做点什么，但我认为这需要我的健康真正变得像，不，有什么东西，我必须做出改变并做点什么，这需要发生才让我真正意识到。我想我还是会做出改变，但我认为我（你知道的）犹豫了一段时间，那是最终的决定性事情，实际上
I want to be able to work from home. I want to be able to pick up my child from school and just yeah, and I want that kind of, I want to feel joy when I come to. to work. I'm not saying that I didn't, but I think I was losing that a little bit because I wanted to do more of the supporting patients with their mental health and less of the other side of my job, which was the main part of the job. So I think that was kind of a bit of a wake-up call as well. And I did think when I was thinking about career changes and options, that was one of the things the salary. But I suppose in that position, I something had to give a little bit. And I there's so many options like when you come into this world there's so many options and okay there's
我希望能够在家工作。我希望能够接我的孩子放学，而且是的，我想要那种，我希望在来上班时感受到快乐。我不是说我没有，但我认为我正在失去这一点，因为我想做更多支持患者心理健康的事情，而减少我工作中的另一部分，那是我工作的主要部分。所以我想这也是一个有点像警钟的东西。当我考虑职业改变和选择时，我确实想过薪水是其中之一。但我想在那个位置上，我必须做出一点妥协。而且我认为当你进入这个世界时有那么多的选项，而且好吧，会有
going to be a pay cut can I manage with that yes I can you know it's a funded course that I did so that was even better and I'm training on the job so I get a job as long as I pass which I did and I get a job at the end of it and then after that there's so many different options for me to progress and I've done it before so I know that I can do it again. So if I'm going to change my career and do all that, I felt like now's the time to do it rather than waiting even longer when I know that I'm not happy. I couldn't see myself in my job in the next five years, 10 years. And I thought, well, I need to make that change. It sounds like your drive. So drive is so important to us and it actually can help us to do really difficult things
降薪，我能应付吗？是的，我可以，我参加的课程是有资助的，所以那就更好了，而且我在工作中接受培训，只要我通过了（我确实通过了），我就会得到一份工作，在那之后，有那么多不同的选择供我晋升，而且我以前做过，所以我知道我能再次做到。所以如果我要改变我的职业并做所有这些，我觉得现在就是做这件事的时候，而不是等到我知道自己不快乐时再等更长的时间。我无法想象自己在未来五年、十年里还做着这份工作。我想，嗯，我需要做出这个改变。听起来你的动力。所以动力对我们来说非常重要，它实际上可以帮助我们做非常困难的事情
because we're just energized by that, but your drive had definitely diminished for the work, which then brings, you know, it just feels a bit more drudgy and it feels like it takes more from you, which again ultimately can impact on you holistically, which is thinking sounds like what you'd experienced. And you then got onto the funded psychological well-being practitioner course.
因为我们对此充满活力，但你的动力对这份工作肯定已经减弱了，这随后带来了（你知道的）感觉有点像苦差事，感觉它从你身上索取了更多，这反过来最终会对你的整体产生影响，这听起来就像你所经历的。然后你进入了有资助的心理健康从业者课程。
Were you able to do that straight from what you were doing? doing from the degree that you'd done or did you have to do any kind of conversion for that? Yeah, no. So I was very lucky actually because I was able to go straight from my course to doing this and they will actually, there's always loads of applicants. So there were 100 applicants for my job and training. So I was luckily one of the two to get through to that based on the experience that I had had. So I'd had some mental health first aid training. I'd worked and supported cancer patients with their mental health. I'd done a lot of work with in the trust with black and ethnic minority champions and setting those up. So because our work is
你能够直接从你正在做的事情、你已经完成的学位中做到这一点，还是为此必须进行任何转换？是的，没有。所以我其实很幸运，因为我能够直接从我的课程转到做这个，而且他们实际上，总是有大量的申请者。所以我的工作和培训有100名申请者。基于我拥有的经验，我很幸运地成为通过的两个人之一。所以我接受过一些心理健康急救培训。我工作并支持过癌症患者的心理健康。我在信托基金中做了很多工作，包括黑人及少数族裔冠军以及建立这些工作。因为我们的工作
very an inclusive practice and works on the community and how we can get more access to people wanting to access mental health. So all those things that I'd done really played a part in getting me that application and getting through that process. So I was, I think I was quite lucky, not lucky, because I'd done the work, but it was enough. And I'd also have a friend who is a clinical psychologist who also, what used to be a radiotherapist and had gone through that journey. So again, just a little bit of help and support to get me through as well. Amazing. And when you can see it, you can be it, right? So actually you know that that's possible. So it's interesting to think, actually, if people are watching this because they're like,
是非常具包容性的实践，致力于社区以及我们如何让更多人想要获得心理健康。所以我所做的所有这些事情确实在帮我获得那个申请并通过那个流程中发挥了作用。所以我想我挺幸运的，不是幸运，因为我已经做了工作，但这已经足够了。而且我还有一个朋友是临床心理学家，她曾经也是一名放射技师，也经历过这段旅程。所以同样，只需一点点帮助和支持就能让我度过难关。太棒了。当你能看到它时，你就能成为它，对吧？所以实际上你知道那是可能的。所以有趣的是，实际上，如果人们观看这个是因为他们觉得，
I really want to do something in mental health, that actually not having a psychology undergraduate degree or a master's conversion is not a barrier to becoming a PWP, which is really, really important. If you were, I'm not going to say that you are, but if you wanted to then go on and become a trainee, Incite or to do something like that, I guess you would need to do a conversion master. to have that kind of stamp of approval from the BPS. Is that what you understand, Manisha? As far as I know, I think that's what you'd need, a conversion masters, I think, to have,
我真的想在心理健康领域做点什么，实际上没有心理学本科学位或硕士转换并不是成为PWP（心理健康从业者）的障碍，这真的、真的很重要。如果你是，我不是说你是，但如果你想继续成为一名培训生，Incite或做类似的事情，我想你需要做一个转换硕士以获得来自BPS（英国心理学会）的批准印章。曼妮莎，这是你所了解的吗？据我所知，我认为这就是你需要的东西，一个转换硕士，我想，为了拥有，
I think there needs to be something like that in place to further that ahead. But this, I think it gives you a really good understanding and, you know, like a baseline and a good level of experience of, not that role, but the extent of the role, you know, It's a very good baseline start, I would say. If someone wants to go in that direction,
我认为有必要设立类似机制来进一步推进这一目标。不过，我认为这能让你对该角色的广度——虽说不是那个具体职位，而是整个职责范围——有一个非常好的理解、基本认知和良好的经验基础。我可以说，这是一个非常好的起点。如果有人想朝着那个方向发展，
I think that this course would be a very good foundation. Great. And once you are qualified as a PWP, essentially you would be able to go on and become, you know, a CBT therapist or something like that as well. Is that right? Yeah, that's correct. So you can train.
我认为这门课程会是一个非常好的基础。太好了。一旦你具备了PWP（心理 wellbeing 实践者）的资格，基本上你就可以继续去成为一名CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗师或类似的角色，对吗？是的，完全正确。所以你可以进行培训。
So again, you generally need a core profession, but you can do a conversion so then you can do the funded course after you've got to have at least a two years gap but then you can do a funded course to train as a cognitive behavioral therapist and that's a year's training from what i understand and then yeah so then you can train to be a cognitive to be a therapist and there's other roles in terms of being a senior or lecturing other things that you can do as well from this but again that would then open up certain possibilities being a cognitive behavioural therapist as well. Yeah. And if anyone's watching this and going, why do I need a two-year gap? It's because if you've
因此，你通常需要一个核心专业背景，但你可以通过修读转换课程，在毕业至少两年后申请有资助的课程，去培训成为一名认知行为治疗师。据我所了解，这需要一年的培训时间。然后是的，你可以培训成为一名认知行为治疗师。除了这个角色之外，还有其他的发展方向，比如担任高级职位或进行讲学等，这些也是你可以从这里延伸出来的。不过，这同样会为你开启成为认知行为治疗师等特定可能性的。是的。如果有人看到这里并会问，为什么我需要两年的间隔期？这是因为如果你
received health education England funding or Health Education Scotland, maybe even Health Education Wales as well, you need to have given two years of not having funded of being qualified before you draw on any future training. And the same is true for people accessing. clinical psychology funded doctorates as well that you need to have had two years. What is worth saying is that you don't necessarily have to have worked in that qualified capacity as a PWP. You could go and do something different, working a different role. It's purely just the funding that you've got to have at least, you know, those two clear years from when your training finishes and the next one starts. So tell us then, Manisha,
获得了英格兰健康教育署（Health Education England）或苏格兰健康教育署（Health Education Scotland）的资助，甚至可能还有威尔士健康教育署（Health Education Wales）的资助，在你在申请任何未来的培训资助之前，你必须在获得资格后至少有两年的时间没有接受过资助。对于申请临床心理学带资博士学位的人来说也是如此，同样需要有两年的间隔。值得一提的是，你不一定非要以PWP的资格身份工作过。你可以去做别的事情，从事不同的角色。这纯粹只跟资助有关，即从你的培训结束到下一次培训开始，必须有至少整整两年的清晰间隔。那么曼尼莎（Manisha），请告诉我们，
what is it like for you having got there? I think how old are you currently, Mnisha? So I'm 42, yeah. So, yeah, it's not being an easy journey, I'd say, for sure. Yeah, and how is it, how is it then being 42 and relatively recently qualified as a PWP? Do you love it? Was it worth it? Oh, yeah, no, definitely.
当你走到这一步时，你的感受是怎样的？曼尼莎，你现在多大了？我42岁了。所以，是的，这段旅程绝对不容易。是的，那么以42岁的年龄并且在不久前刚刚获得PWP资格，是一种什么样的体验？你喜欢它吗？这一切值得吗？哦，是的，绝对值得。
It's definitely worth it. It was definitely the right thing to do. Yeah, and I think those little nudges. that I listened to were definitely in the right. I never thought, why, well, sometimes I did think why I've done this when I was studying, but not more so I always knew that it was the right decision. It wasn't easy at all. I think changing careers later on in life, having a family, working full-time and studying
绝对值得。这绝对是正确的事情。是的，而且我认为我听从的那些内心的微小指引绝对是正确的方向。我从来没有想过为什么——好吧，有时我在学习的时候确实想过我为什么要这样做，但我更多的时候是确信这是一个正确的决定。这绝非易事。我认为在人生的后期改变职业，要兼顾家庭、全职工作和学习，
is really tough and it is a really intense course. You kind of told that before you start, but I think until you go through it, you don't really realise how difficult it is. and then when you're trying to juggle lots of different things. So, yeah, definitely being very organized and managing your own self-care, I think throughout the course is really, really important because it is really tough. But I think because it's for a year,
真的是非常艰难，而且这是一门非常密集的课程。你在开始之前就会被告知这一点，但我认为直到你真正经历它，你才真正意识到它是多么困难。当你试图同时应付许多不同的事情时更是如此。所以，是的，在整个课程期间，保持高度的组织性并管理好自己的自我照顾真的是非常非常重要，因为这确实很艰难。但因为这只是一年的时间，
you can see that end in sight a lot quicker than if it was a longer course. So, yeah, now I think it's trusting that you have the capability and the ability to do those things once you've got the interview, you and you know going through it you've been assessed you've got those skills you can do it can get through it and I think it's having that trust in yourself that belief in yourself that each thing is going to be difficult but you'll get through it sometimes you know the shift in certain things that have happened along the way like getting used to doing treatments with clients getting used to doing assessments with clients there's a period where you think oh my god no I cannot do this how am
你可以更快地看到终点。所以，是的，现在我认为最重要的是相信自己有能力、有实力在获得面试机会并经历这一切评估后，去做好这些事情。你已经具备了这些技能，你能够做到，你能够度过难关。我认为这就是要对自己有这种信任，对自己有这种信念：每一件事情都会很困难，但你总能挺过去。有时，你一路上会经历某些转变，比如习惯于为来访者进行治疗，习惯于为来访者做评估，会有一段时间你会想：天哪，不，我怎么可能做得到这一切呢？你怎么
going to be able to do all of this but then you do and it shifts along the course this those little shifts you learn a bit more and it's the next thing how i can get through supervision and do all my cases and then it's the next thing then you just again as the caseload increases it's those little shifts but always remembering you know what i'm here for a reason i've got through and i can get through so i think it's just having that that belief in yourself and using the support that you have around you because this field is a very supportive and compassionate field and i think pulling on those support that you've got to kind of get you through well because I had a lot of difficulty in personal circumstances, so I did need a lot of support
能够做到这一切呢？但最终你确实做到了，随着课程的推进，这些小小的转变会发生，你学到了更多，接下来的事情是如何应对督导并处理好所有的个案，然后是下一个挑战，随着个案数量的增加，就是这些循序渐进的转变，但始终要记住：你知道吗，我来到这里是有原因的，我一路走过来了，我也能继续挺过去。所以我觉得这只是需要保持对自己的信念，并利用你身边的支持，因为这个领域是一个非常支持和富有同情心的领域，我觉得要依靠你所拥有的支持来帮你度过难关。因为我的个人情况遇到了很多困难，所以我确实需要很多支持，
and it did mean extending my deadlines to kind of get through. But there's no shame in that if you need the help and support, go get it. We need it as much as anybody else. Absolutely. And if people are listening to this and I'm like, oh, I'm not quite sure that I'll necessarily meet the academic standards of, you know, putting in my case presentations or my essays or my assignments or my reflective pieces, whatever it is. Is there support from, you know, the academic centre for writing or your tutors to help you meet the expectations? There's a lot of support.
这也意味着我不得不延长截止日期才能坚持下来。但如果需要帮助和支持，寻求帮助并不丢人，去寻求吧。我们和其他人一样都需要帮助。绝对是这样。如果人们听到这里，心里在想：哦，我不太确定自己是否一定能达到学术标准，比如提交个案汇报、论文、作业或反思报告等等。学术中心的写作指导或导师会提供支持来帮助你达到期望吗？这里有大量的支持。
Like even for writing, there's like skills at university. There's loads of different support that you can do. There's from time management to organising, you know, there's lots of support that you, and it's just about accessing that support. You told about it, but then sometimes people don't access it. I used it and I thought it was really helpful and it helped me to get through the course and different things that I was finding difficult. You know, everyone is really supportive.
甚至在写作方面，大学也有各种技能支持。你可以获得许许多多不同类型的支持。从时间管理到组织规划，有许多支持可供利用，关键就在于去获取这些支持。人们会告诉你这些，但有时人们并不去获取。我使用过这些支持，我认为它们真的很有帮助，帮助我度过了课程中的难关，也解决了我发现困难的各种问题。你知道，每个人都非常支持你。
So nobody wants you to fail. So there is the support there. It's just about, I think, accessing it and utilising it and taking on the advice that you're kind of given. Yeah, and using that really. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, I think even when I was on training, so I think I think I I was 27 when I started, and there was a 40-year-old and a 43-year-old, and that was quite
所以没有人希望你失败。支持是存在的，关键在于去获取它、利用它，并采纳给予你的建议。是的，真的去运用它。是的，绝对如此。而且，你知道，我想甚至在我接受培训的时候，我想我开始时是27岁，当时有一个40岁和一个43岁的学员，在那个时代这相当
radical at those times, but actually it was really important for the cohort, but also for those people to not invalidate themselves, to not think, oh, I'm too old, like it's, you know, I've passed my time, like, we all deserve to thrive, don't we? And with the idea that maybe retirement is maybe like a thing that may or may not ever happen for us. If we're going to carry on working, maybe we're choosing to carry on working, then we deserve to be fulfilled in what we do is what I would say. Would you agree, Mnisha? Oh yes, definitely.
激进，但实际上这对于整个学员群体非常重要，对那些人来说，也是为了不否定他们自己，不让他们去想“哦，我太老了，这就像是，你知道的，我的时代已经过去了”。我们所有人都值得蓬勃发展，对吗？考虑到退休对我们来说可能是一个或许会发生也或许永远不会发生的事情。如果我们打算继续工作，也许我们正选择继续工作，那么我们就值得从我们所做的事情中获得成就感，这就是我想说的。你同意吗，曼尼莎？哦，是的，绝对同意。
I think, you know, life's for living. Who wants to spend their time at work and feel miserable? Well, I definitely don't. So I think, and if you feel like that, then that's, you know, a definite sign to kind of something needs to change or something needs to give unless you can feel happy and content there being in that same environment, then find, you know, like, you know, then my advice would be to carry on. But if you're not happy, then there's nothing worse than spending your time at work, not feeling happy with what you're doing. so that, yeah, that would be a big sign to kind of do something different and change. And even at my age, I never think that I'm too old to do anything because I don't see age as a thing. You know, I feel quite young inside.
我想，你知道，人生就是用来生活的。谁愿意把时间浪费在工作中还觉得痛苦呢？反正我绝对不愿意。所以我想，如果你有这种感觉，那么这（你知道的）绝对是一个信号，说明有些事情需要改变，或者有些事情需要做出让步。除非你能在同一个环境中感到快乐和满足，那么很好，你知道的，我的建议就是坚持下去。但如果你不快乐，没有什么比把时间花在工作中却对所做的事情感到不快乐更糟糕的事情了。所以，是的，这会是一个强烈的信号，促使你去做出不同的尝试和改变。即使到了我这个年纪，我也从不觉得自己做任何事太老了，因为我并不把年龄当回事。你知道的，我内心感觉自己还很年轻。
So, but yeah, obviously you've got different things to consider at an age in terms of finances, potentially children or other responsibilities that people might have. So it's not easy. but it's not impossible either you can do it and I think now's a perfect time you know what you want yeah like maybe rather than trying to push down that thought that maybe I want to do something different allow it some oxygen you know
所以，是的，很显然，到了这个年纪，你必须从财务、潜在的孩子或其他可能承担的责任等不同方面去考虑问题。所以这并不容易，但也不是不可能的，你完全可以做到。而且我认为现在是绝佳的时机，你知道自己想要什么。是的，与其试图压抑那个“或许我想做点别的事情”的想法，不如给它注入一些活力，你知道吗？
actually if I was to take myself seriously if I was to give myself permission to do this to fulfil this career aspiration and if I was to really think about maybe it's okay for me to choose what I do maybe some of the other choices I've made have made sense at the time but now the age I'm at right now
实际上，如果我认真对待自己，如果我给自己准许去这样做，去实现这个职业志向，如果我真正去思考——也许我可以选择我想做的事情，也许我过去做过的一些选择在当时是有道理的，但现在以我目前的年纪，
maybe it's okay for me to empower myself to meet my own needs to put myself first and to know that all of the people around me will actually be happier and thrive more if I am authentically driving. Yeah. I think what I did is I started to think about what is it about my job that I like
也许我可以赋能自己去满足自己的需求，把我自己放在首位，并知道我周围的所有人实际上会因为我真正充满活力地生活而感到更加快乐和蓬勃发展。是的。我想我当时做的是，我开始思考我的工作中有哪些是我喜欢的，
and what is it that I don't like or, you know, to try and kind of filter out, what is it that lights me up? What am I liking? What do I see in other jobs that I think, oh, I like want a bit of that, you know, and that kind of really helped me. But I think I always have that knowing in terms of psychology and mental health and that support really was always there. And sometimes I think it always is, it's just if we're listening. listening really. Yeah. Okay. And do you think reflective journals are helpful? Did you keep any notes at work about the things that lit you up when you felt really good? I had notes on my phone. I'd keep like a little bit of a positive log so I'd look for like feedback I'd get or anything that
有哪些是我不喜欢的内容，或者试图去筛选：是什么点亮了我？我喜欢什么？我在其他工作中看到了什么，让我觉得“哦，我也想拥有那样的一点点”，你知道的，这种思考真的对我很有帮助。但我认为，对于心理学、心理健康和支持的那种内在认知一直都在那里。有时我认为它一直都在，只是看我们是否真的在聆听。是的。好的。那么你认为反思日志有帮助吗？你在工作中是否有记下那些让你感到点亮、让你感觉极好的事情？我把笔记记在手机上。我会保留一点正向记录，寻找我得到的反馈或者任何
you know, like I'd really light me up. And I think having all that kind of evidence was kind of telling me these are the things that I'm good at and these are that's where my skills are and this is a I think it gives you those signals for your direction and where to go and you know all of that and I felt like more of that was coming away from radiotherapy for me so it was put everything started being like the coaching even the inclusive practice in terms of the champions was all linked to radio therapy but not the con it wasn't the main bread and butter. So that was my biggest sign that actually it's not here, it's not in this environment, it's somewhere else. Yeah. I have something on my phone as a phone album called Smile File,
你知道的，真正能点亮我的事情。我认为拥有所有这些证据就是在告诉我，这些是我擅长的东西，这些是我的技能所在，我认为这为你指明了方向和前进的道路。我感觉到在放射治疗的工作中，有越来越多的事情与我渐行渐远，所以一切都开始转向像辅导这样的工作，甚至包括作为倡导者的包容性实践，虽然都与放射疗法有关，但并不是核心的主业。这就是我最大的信号，实际上它并不在这里，它不在这个环境中，而在其他地方。是的。我在手机里有一个名为“微笑档案”（Smile File）相册，
which sounds like it's very similar to what you have, but things that happen that make me feel really good. It might even be a screenshot of a note of a reflection I've had. It might be, you know, a feedback that someone's given me about some of our work that we've done together. It might be a book testimonial. It might be someone saying, oh my God, I've got. I've got into clinical training and you're a big reason why like and all of those are in a smile file so you know when you're just when you want a few different reasons you might want to reflect you might want to you know validate yourself when you're feeling like you're having a really tricky day or you might want to use that to refocus your energies like but i've got that to draw on for a
听起来这和你的做法非常相似，里面记录着那些让我感觉非常美好的事情。它甚至可能是我做过的一条反思笔记的截图。它可能是别人对我们共同完成的一些工作给出的反馈。它可能是书评。它可能是有人说：“天哪，我进入临床培训了，你是其中的一大原因”——所有这些都被保存在“微笑档案”里，所以当你只需要一些不同的理由时，你可能会想要反思，当你觉得自己正经历着非常棘手的一天时，你可能想要肯定自己，或者你可能想要利用它来重新聚焦你的精力，但我手头有这些资料可以汲取各种各样的动力。所以，是的，如果你还没有一个“微笑档案”，我想我也需要去弄一个，因为这听起来是个很好的习惯，只是形式略有不同。是的，它把所有的东西都集中在了一个地方。所以，是的，我确实使用笔记，但随后我会给这些笔记截图，我觉得这些内容非常适合放进“微笑档案”里。“微笑档案”，是的。“微笑档案”。非常感谢你抽出时间，曼尼莎，我希望你能继续真正享受
variety of reasons so yeah if you don't already have a smile file i think i need to get that instead because it sounds like a habit, but just in a different way, but yeah. Yeah, it kind of brings all the things together into one place. So, yeah, I do use notes, but then I'll take a screenshot of the notes, I think would be well suited within the smile file. Smile file, yeah. Smile file. Thank you so much for your time, Manisha, and I hope that you continue to really enjoy
作为一名PWP的时光，你知道的，提供优质的服务，在那里你活出最真实的自我，践行你的价值观，并深知这样做真的非常重要。非常感谢你与我们的观众、我们的听众分享你的故事，因为这真的很重要。而且，你知道的，这个播客最强大的地方之一——我们现在已经录制了200多期节目——就是人们会说：“哦，实际上，这真的给了我很多启发，
being a PWP and, you know, providing a quality service where you're living your authentic best self, living your values and knowing that it's really important that you do. So thank you so much for sharing your story with our viewers, with our listeners, because it really matters. And, you know, one of the most powerful things about this podcast, we're over 200 episodes in now, is that people are like, oh, actually, this is really giving me food for thought,
让我去思考重新培训，去思考如何让自己快乐，去做一些真实的事情，去践行我的价值观。”你的故事非常完美地概括了这一切。非常感谢你。也谢谢你邀请我来。不用谢。感谢你的时间，并祝愿你接下来的一切都顺利。谢谢你，玛丽安。谢谢。非常感谢大家的观看，也要再次感谢我们出色的嘉宾曼尼莎抽出时间。这番话点燃了你心中的什么想法？这是否带给你认同感，这是否是你一直需要的心理准许？我很想在评论区知道。我很想知道，这为你开启了什么，或者这为你继续坚定什么信念提供了支持。如果你在YouTube上观看，请点个赞。请留个评论。
for thinking about retraining, for thinking about making myself happy, doing something authentic and that meets my values and your story so well encapsulates all of that. Thank you so much. Thank you for having me as well. You're so welcome. Thank you for your time and wishing you well with whatever comes next for you. Thank you, Marianne. Thank you. Thank you so much for watching and again to our fabulous guest, Manisha, for her time. What has this ignited for you? Is this validating, is this the permission slip you needed? I would love to know in the comments. I would love to know, you know, what this has started for you or what this has continued to validate for you. If you're watching on YouTube, please do drop a like. Please do drop a comment.
如果你在Spotify上，你也可以这样做。在Apple Podcasts上，你可以对节目进行评分和评论。如果你能这么做，我将感激不尽。无论你在哪里观看，订阅或关注这个节目都是你能为任何你欣赏的播客或创作者做的最贴心的事。如果你能这样做，我将不胜感激。是的，这能帮助我继续提供这些你觉得大有裨益的内容。如果你正在考虑重新培训，或者正在进行重新培训，甚至只是将其作为你的第一职业，我想你会发现“有志心理学家会员”（the aspiring psychologist membership）是一个极其有用的资源。我想说的是，现在加入永远不会太早。
And if you're on Spotify, you can do the same there too. On Apple Podcast, you can rate and review the show. And I'd be so grateful if you did. Wherever you're watching, subscribing or following the show is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster or creator that you rate. If you would do that, I would be so, so grateful. And yeah, it helps me to keep providing this content that you find hopefully so useful. If you are thinking about retraining, or if you are underway with retraining, or even just making it your first career, I think you will find the aspiring psychologist membership an incredibly useful resource. And what I would say is it's never too early to join.
如果你在使用 Spotify，也可以在那里这样做。在 Apple Podcast 上，你可以为节目评分和写评论。如果你能这样做，我将不胜感激。无论你在哪里收看，订阅或关注节目是对任何播客或创作者所能做的最好的事情。如果你能这样做，我会非常非常感激。是的，这能帮助我继续提供这些你觉得很有用的内容。如果你正在考虑转行，或者正在转行中，甚至只是将其作为你的第一职业，我想你会发现“有抱负的心理学家会员”（the aspiring psychologist membership）是一个非常有用的资源。我想说的是，加入永远不会太早。
For that matter, it's never too late to join. If you've got an interview coming up, you know, dive in. People have got interviews, have got jobs just from watching content, even on replay. But the live stuff is pretty good too. When you do join, you'll get access to the last three years of membership content as well. So there's nothing not to like. people speak really highly of it. If you've got any questions about whether it might be right for you, please don't be a stranger. Please do let me know. And if you'd like to join the membership or check
再说回来，现在加入也永远不算晚。如果你接下来有面试，你知道的，直接开始就行。有人光是看内容，甚至是看回放，就拿到了面试和工作。不过直播的内容也很棒。当你加入后，你还可以获得过去三年会员内容的访问权限。所以没有什么理由不喜欢它，大家对它的评价都非常高。如果你对它是否适合你有任何疑问，请不要客气，一定要让我知道。如果你想加入会员或者查看
it out, you can do by going to www.aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com. If you find validation and inspiration in other people's stories, I think you'll really like the books, the clinical psychologist collective and the aspiring psychologist collective. And there's links for all of these things in my description and show notes. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
详情，可以访问 www.aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com。如果你能从别人的故事中找到认同感和灵感，我想你会非常喜欢这两本书：《临床心理学家集锦》和《有抱负的心理学家集锦》。这些内容的链接都在我的简介和节目文稿中。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。